hello everyone
I hope you're all having a wonderful
conference so far I'm really excited
about this talk so quick introduction
I'm Sam Nelson I'm the product lead for
you - these data programs and luckily
you will not be hearing from me but I
get to introduce Robert Monroe to talk
about how machine learning and data
science can save lives Robert is a
computational linguist with an expert in
machine learning and natural language
processing and he's he's founded several
AI companies worked in a whole bunch of
different environments from Sierra Leone
Haiti the Amazon to San Francisco Sydney
and London he's a he's also worked with
organizations like startups Amazon even
the United Nations and he is currently
the CTO of CrowdFlower
previously he he got a PhD from Stanford
and has published over 50 papers in the
artificial intelligence field so please
give it up for Robert
[Applause]
everyone's great to be here and thanks
for joining for the 4:00 p.m. session I
know there's plenty of other
distractions right now something we talk
about a topic that's really dinner my
heart so I work in an artificial
intelligence more broadly but today I'm
going to talk about an area that I have
a special passion in and it actually
predates being an AI professional to
working in machine learning for disaster
response and economic development so my
path to AI was a little different for
many other peoples so this is a
photograph I took in 2007 at that time I
was living in Sierra Leone working in
neighboring Liberia for the United
Nations High Commission for Refugees so
I was working in refugee camps
installing solar power systems at
clinics and schools supporting those
refugee camps and this picture here is
taken outside one of these clinics this
gentleman here is strapping vaccines in
refrigerated containers to his bicycle
to go from a clinic that we were will
power in to outlying areas to deliver
those vaccines so this is a part of the
world where there's very little in the
way of motorized transport and even
medicine is being delivered in a in a
very very manual and low-tech way this
was at the clinic itself you can see it
looks pretty rundown these are kids
playing with the cardboard box just like
anywhere else in the world and we had a
moment when we were working on this
clinic where we heard stories about more
refugees coming over the border from
Cote d'Ivoire into the the neighboring
Valley but we weren't able to find out
anything about them so we didn't know if
there were ten refugees or there were
10,000 refugees no one in this the
village that we were in really knew what
was happening in the valley just that
rumors that happened that people were
coming over the border and we were the
ones working there and you know in the
refugee camp for the UN if anyone should
be able to find out
anything about them it should have been
us ultimately in a couple of days that
we were there we weren't able to get any
more useful information have to report
this back to the capital Monrovia right
I'd hope that someone else would would
take care of it and what I found to be
really crazy at this time was that I had
five bars of cell phone reception on my
phone at that time I had perfect
reception something I don't get here in
Mountain View very often and I've no
doubt that members of this group of
refugees also had cell phones
they'll probably bouncing the signals
off the same tower that I was but I had
no way to connect with them and even if
I did connect with them they would have
spoken you know any number of maybe half
a dozen local languages for which no
services existed to help me understand
what they wanted there's no machine
translation for those languages even AI
that we took for granted ten years ago
like search engines or spam filtering
wouldn't have worked in any usable way
and in those particular languages and so
this moment really showed me that while
I we had solved the problem of connect
in the world the the ability to bring
services to everyone in the world
especially AI services so growing was
really really lacking and so at that
time I've been working as a professional
software developer I studied artificial
intelligence doesn't undergraduate even
published papers on it but didn't intend
it to be my career and so I really took
a career change after this I went back
to graduate school got my PhD here at
Stanford and then focused just on this
topic how can we bring artificial
intelligence tamal languages and to put
this into perspective here's a useful
graph which maps every single human
communication this year by number would
spoken so the green is spoken language
but what I'm doing right now so person
to person spoken language divided by
language so Mandarin Chinese being the
largest English Hindi and Spanish each
making up about 5% of the world's spoken
conversations daily I'm Arabic just just
slightly less there down here is how
much is
technology enabled so 7% of our
communications today are digital most is
still direct spoken language so here we
have phone base SMS and phone calls in
blue and then internet-based red on the
right there and to put the online
communication in perspective if we
treated every single photograph online
with the adage of it's worth a thousand
words it come to a block about this big
so even though images especially video
are now taking up more of Internet
traffic in terms of where volume in
terms of how we're communicating with
people language is still by far the most
most dominant form of communication and
so also to put that the scale of this in
perspective every three months the
world's text messages alone by word
count double the word count of every
single book ever written so those of you
who are as old as me might remember
actual libraries and and how many books
they were and imagine what a tiny
percent of the the world's literature is
really in that one library and and then
think that every book since the start of
time is still less than what's being
communicated by text message every three
months so there's a lot of information
being shared digitally fossum pause
print communication it's more than
anything on this graph here the same is
true for any one social network we
haven't seen really a one large network
takeover in terms of amount of
communications put things in perspective
that the Twitter firehose about the size
of the dot in the I above English which
gives us a nice benchmark for how hard
it is that the capturing process and
understand this volume of information
because most organizations right now
would say that processing the full
Twitter firehose would be beyond their
their technology capabilities and to put
the the diversity into perspective is
about 7,000 languages in the world the
ones explicitly mapped here or adjust
the the top one percent so we have a
huge diversity of languages for which we
have very little technologies right now
the only thing that's not mapped here is
email spam you'd be larger than anything
except Mandarin so spam is absolutely
huge what ends up in your spam box is
actually only a tiny percent of what
gets sent to your email address so short
message communication so SMS and instant
messaging make up about 2% of all
communications in the world and in a lot
of the world you'll go to places where
this is the first form of written
communication ever most languages are
traditionally not spoken like not
written languages only spoken languages
and people are writing in those
languages via text message instant
messaging for the first time and so this
is the largest and it's the most
linguistically diverse form of
communication that has ever existed I
probably ever will exist as we lose a
number of languages in the world so
won't take a guess how many PhDs have
focused on large volumes of short
messages and low resource languages
close to zero just one that was mine you
weren't listening I said that earlier I
think this is a really important topic
and I'm really looking for people who
can kind of like take up this as an area
to focus their research on for the
reasons that I outlined today because
it's really really important to give an
idea of how poorly something is
supported your browser probably won't
show Sundanese script so actually this
does show some - these scripts the first
time ever given this presentation words
turn it up so by default even though
Sundanese is one of the 1% most widely
spoken languages in the world
it doesn't ship by default with most
browsers and to put that number of
speakers in perspective Sudanese
speakers outnumber the population New
York London Tokyo and Moscow combined
I'm sure you've all heard of these
cities before but you haven't heard of
probably haven't heard of Sundanese
speakers and you can be honest here how
many of you misread or misheard son
Denis Sundanese as Sudanese right most
of you thank you for your honesty so
Sudanese is a form of Arabic
Sundanese is a language spoken in
Indonesia and so we have a real blind
spot for knowing about the existence of
languages which I think carries over to
the technologies that we have to support
in them and just so you know what what
Sundanese is Sundanese is spoken in in
this this region of Indonesia the center
of that region is where Barack Obama
spent some of his youth so it's not like
it's an area that that's disconnected to
the US and what's crazy is that it's on
the the island of Java and there were
two scripts of Java Sundanese and
Javanese neither of them ship with your
browser but your browser does ship with
JavaScript a programming language named
after that very same Island so this is
the breakdown of languages that most of
our data is moving towards so as more of
the world comes online interact with
people by phone or Internet enabled
communication this is going to be the
the breakdown of languages and this is a
real gap here because English reading
makes up about 5% of communications
daily but it makes up about 95 percent
of the research and technology for
processing languages so 95 percent of
technologies out there that only work in
English rather they work well and in
English and this is a bias that is
continuing today with many many
organizations launching technologies
just in English and then worrying about
other languages later which sometimes
means not at all and we all expect
machines to listen so 5 in every 10,000
words are directed at machines not
people and this is increasing mainly
search engines when you think about it
you really ask you know a machine
something when you're typing into a
search engine but increasingly with
speech recognition systems in home
devices as well so if you speak to your
phone or if you have an in-home device
and and so we need not just text
processes in these languages we need
speech as well and I think it's
interesting to ask though what does it
mean to connect so are we how are we
obligated to to connect
with people that that we can connect
with and so one of the first ways that I
was combined in artificial intelligence
and disaster response was in 2010 so in
January of 2010 an earthquake struck
Haiti most local services failed but
most cellphone towers remained
functional so more than a hundred
thousand people died almost immediately
in the earthquake and more than a
million were left homeless and so while
they're connected to the world there
were no local services with which to
respond to this disaster and so messages
started streaming in people were able to
send messages to their family to their
friends outside of Haiti post them
online and they look like this now so
this is in Haitian Creole I imagine that
no one in in this room knows how to
speak Haitian Creole it's a language
really only spoken in Haiti or by the
Haitian diaspora but all the
International responders going into
Haiti at the time only had English as a
common language so there was a gap
between what people were saying and what
could be understood in order affect our
response and this is what these messages
translate to so it's a family that needs
food and water
it's the report of a need for a search
and rescue in a church it's a hospital
saying that they're about to run out of
supplies it's emergency could get
anywhere somebody undergoing a child
delivery so working with the number of
people we set up essentially at 9-1-1
service which allowed anyone within
Haiti to send a text message to
basically like this this short code a
9-1-1 like like number code for six
three six and report whatever they need
it or whatever they were observing and
so my role was to run the first stage of
this where we could translate these into
structured reports that anyone could
understand so i found and managed 2000
members of the Haitian diaspora who
could come online and use actually the
same crowdsourcing platform I now work
at CrowdFlower so eight years later I
joined the company that whose software
we used for
this and these 2000 volunteers could
read a message when it came in and
Haitian Creole translated into English
categorize it is about food security
water click on a map where they knew the
location to be and something that
structured report in English categorized
and geo located could be stream back to
the emergency responders within the
country in this case was mostly the US
Coast Guard who were there affected in
their response so in all these 2000
volunteers came from 49 companies around
the world and were able to transfer this
from being a volunteer effort about one
month later to being paid workers so
these forty paid workers remain employed
as crowdsource workers within Haiti to
this day they've collectively earned
more than a million dollars it's one
addition to effect in a response
it meant that we're able to create more
economic value in the local economy as
well and so to to give you an idea of
how important it was to engage this
community here is a map here and imagine
you'd already solve the problem of
translation where you took this haitian
creole laptop and you translated it to
english down the bottom and then you're
looking for Oh cap on this map so see if
you can see the village of Oh cap and
this is actually something we did work
on at the time so taking these human
translations were able to feed them but
the Microsoft and Google's machine
translation engines and within just a
couple of weeks of that earthquake both
of them had shipped machine translation
for fresh and Creole
so we had partially solved the
translation problem with with AI at that
time but the geolocation problem was
still tough so what if I told you Oh cap
was in here how can you find that now
still no what about if we zoom in again
and I and I tell you it's here probably
not right so cap is actually slang for
cap passion compassion is the second
largest city in Haiti used to be the
capital if you know anything about Haiti
you've heard of this city but if you
don't know slang and in Haitian Creole
you might not know that that Oh cap is
is slang for this area and it makes
sense when you look
right like in a lot of languages the sea
can become the K which is why its cap
with a k' not a C and O can just mean
location like also you'll see in other
languages so it makes sense when you
know about it but if you're not coming
to train the AI with that local
knowledge then you're not able to get
the correct location and in fact that
the local knowledge here would tell you
that Sacred Heart Hospital is actually
in a town maybe 30 miles south of the
the village itself and sis local
knowledge was super vital and so I think
is a good example here of how this local
knowledge can come from anywhere so here
we have workers collaborate collaborate
in online forum trying to define one
location so delilah lives just up the
road in San Francisco she's asking for a
place called Thomason I'm she doesn't
know where it is a PO does know what -
immediately responds with the longitude
and latitude zoo they have to click on a
map to generate that opposed in in
Montreal and he says this area after
Catherine ville is it's not a Google map
we have no street names so he doesn't
have to read the name he just knows
where it is he can click on the map
generate the longitude and latitude and
find that find that location there in
this particular case it was a breech
birth and the US Coast Guard were able
to dispatch a team to help deliver that
child and sorry is a really good example
of the ability to make a real time
difference in the world from anywhere on
the planet
apple says you know we know this place
like my pocket it's like also French
phrase I've know it locked my pocket I
don't like the back of my hand and
Delilah's thank God you were here which
i think is interesting because here can
be anywhere right is she were referred
to online forum to Montreal to Haiti to
San Francisco and so they were able to
do this for 480 thousand messages in
near-real-time and no one had really
looked at doing online crowd-sourced
translation before no one had done it in
in real-time in industry or in academic
contexts let alone in in the Disaster
Response context it so get an idea for
80 messages look like eighty thousand
messages we can zoom out and see that
that's not eighty thousand
that's 80,000 messages so if we printed
them out in 12-point font it would
pretty much cover this wall here we did
this with an average turnaround of four
and a half minutes and as far as we know
we we know there's dozens of lives that
were saved by this and we're told there
were hundreds the largest individual
group of people were internally
displaced refugees in a formal camp of
2,500 people who had received no Wade
especially no medicine water for several
days and so I think there's more of this
process that we could automate with
artificial intelligence and so from this
event back in 2010 is something that
I've been fortunate to help where there
are a number of times since so I'm not
going to talk about my my PhD which was
in this area but if you're interested
please do read it
someone has to at some point I think
what's more interesting global example
that I worked on elsewhere which is in
epidemics so disease outbreaks are the
world's single greatest killer like
nothing kills more people then illnesses
almost all of which are completely
preventable so no organization is
tracking them all you've probably seen a
movie where people are in use like a
wool room and there's a huge map of the
world and it was like a heat map that
pings every time there's a disease
outbreak right like that doesn't exist
and the budget that wouldn't that movie
is probably more that goes into any one
organization for actually tracking
diseases and so this is super scary and
if we look back at human diseases only
one has been eradicated in the last 75
years which is smallpox we might be
getting there with polio soon but we're
not there quite yet
an increase in air travel has increased
dramatically in the last 75 years so the
potential for a large outbreak is very
real and this is an inherently
linguistic problem as well so 90% of the
world's ecological diversity comes from
this thin strip in the tropics and
within that the ecological diversity
includes although all the pathogens
everything
whether it's a virus or a bacteria or a
parasite that is potentially deadly to
us pretty much that same 10% of the
world also has 90% of the world's and
Christic diversity no one's really sure
why that is border doesn't be is that
the first time that someone identifies a
disease outbreak chances are it's in any
one of 6,000 languages probably not
English which means that those first
reports can often be missed if no one's
monitoring those languages and we can we
can go back and look at some of the
biggest disease outbreaks ever and see
open reports weeks months or years
before it was identified by virologist
and epidemiologist has been a new
disease outbreak so in the case of swine
flu we can find spanish-language reports
in in Mexico months before we identified
this as a new version of the flu which
was much more deadly so about 10% of the
world is said to be infected at some
point h1 n v or bird flu we can go back
and find cables out of Hong Kong and
surrounding areas
weeks before it was identified as a new
disease with more than 50 percent
fatality rate thankfully never mutated
to the point where you could jump
person-to-person but if it did I could
have been devastating in the case of HIV
we can go back decades and find early
reports that if felt was put in front of
the right epidemiologist over ologist
and we would have got to the that sooner
so simply finding these early reports
can prevent epidemics
epidemic IQ was a company I worked on
this now part of companies to exist code
Mehta by odor which to epidemic tracking
and using a combination of AI and human
intelligence were able to scale to
millions of potential reports a day so
would take in anything that might look
like it's reported a disease from from
blogs from traditional media from social
media pause out that information so
what's the disease name how many people
infected how many people have been
treated how many fatalities are there
people being transport what was the mode
of transportation and
and everything that the AI wasn't
certain about it was able to give that
to talk Russell's workers to micro
tasker's who in the thousands who spoke
all these languages were able to sift
through correct the AI output which in
turn provided new training data to make
the AI better look to see it was
actually a new novel report that we
cared about which meant that the domain
experts really only had to look at a few
hundred reports a day out of the
millions of potential reports that they
came in so they have a manageable number
where they really could take in
information from from all across the
world this is something that even in
more developed parts the world we found
be fairly effective so there was a coli
outbreak in in Germany in 2010 it had
two thousand eleven or other had a
number of fatalities and so we were able
to show that with AI tracking local
German newspapers that we could get
ahead of the European CDC in terms of
track in the number of infections and
the number of fatalities across the
region and this is something that I
build on a number of times since so
another really good example in the
health space was a company I was
founding CEO of about three years ago
now partnered with the Child Protection
Wing of the UN looking at maternal
health so in this case looking
especially across West Africa in Nigeria
looking at 12 different languages for
where those an SMS service where a small
group of experts health experts based in
city centers in Nigeria could manage
text messages back and forth to the the
first thousand days from when a woman
realized that she was pregnant until a
thousand days after that so going
through the birth and the early
vaccinations weights of the child and
having a system where you have these
experts in in in both the geography of
Nigeria and the the various local
language is unable to pull out the right
information intent of the sender
categorizes about orphans and vulnerable
children and health nutrition etc
detect the language bring out locations
as well so we could see if there are
there any trends across the region this
was something that was able to have this
jewel model where a small number of
people were able to provide that that
training data to bootstrap a more
accurate system that could scale much
larger this is something that extends to
computer vision as well so that same
company when a hurricane sandy hit we
worked with FEMA and the Civil Air
Patrol to provide the first damage
assessments in New York and New Jersey
so following a disaster in the u.s. the
Civil Air Patrol are often the first to
fly over that they'll take photographs
to try and tile the whole region and
then people need to quickly do damage
assessments across those tiled areas
however the the size of the area that
was affected here and the fact is a very
dense urban area meant that it was
beyond their typical resources to do
damage assessment from every single
photograph that they took so this is
something that we were able to
crowdsource and simply get people to say
just look okay not okay or actually bad
for every single photograph and this is
what femur used as one of their data
sources to help decide where to deploy
resources and we went back later and got
professional GIS experts who work in
disaster response to do the same radians
and found that crowdsource workers where
the right quality controls could be just
as accurate as these domain experts are
able to show that this is this is a use
case where you can distribute it to two
more people for effective processing I
think what's exciting about advances in
computer vision is that even you know
like five or six years ago you wouldn't
really have thought to try to do this as
an automated task computer vision just
wasn't there yet it is today and so this
is a great example of one of the areas
where my current company CrowdFlower is
work you know I'm or a figure-eight the
company is changing name we're a figure
right now for all kinds of image
processing so in this particular one
we're looking for poaches of elephants
so this is providing training data in
this case identifying elephants it'll
also be identifying that you can see
this there's people down here so that we
can power computer vision algorithms
that even from a great distance are able
to identify when there are people
potentially moving near herds of
elephants who might be poachers that
someone needs to take one notice of in
terms of what these workforces will look
like there's a lot of a lot of people
doing this so I saw an estimate recently
by I think whose element AI where they
said there's only about 10,000 people
working in artificial intelligence I'm
not sure what they used for for their
metrics about who counts is working in
artificial intelligence certainly on the
the marketplace that we run a
CrowdFlower we have hundreds of
thousands of people working in creating
training data and they're the ones with
the records at local knowledge and
skills to create the these annotations
that we never could and so in this case
it's a group of women working in a
center outside of I think I'll cut her
in this case and in an area where
traditionally there wouldn't be jobs
information economy and there these are
experts in self-driving cars so they can
look at an image they'll immediately
know okay this street sign it's in
Germany I know the rules there which is
more than I would know and I were able
to annotate these pictures to provide
the training data so I think there
there's this incredible wealth of
knowledge in people globally that we can
connect to the people building the
algorithms in order to train and adapt
for our use cases so how can you
contribute I think that the best way to
do this is is in the jobs that you have
or other jobs that you'll be taking
making sure that the technology your
shape in it can support as many
languages and there's many use cases as
possible
every technology I've used in disaster
response it's been a technology that is
already very basic it's it's been AWS
it's been a commercial crowdsourcing
service there's not separate
humanitarian technologies we use the
same tech as
everyone else is of your technology or
ready ships and more languages the
computer vision can be adapted to
environments other than just say like
the roads in in California
then you'll laying the foundation for a
more inclusive world for artificial
intelligence including those of us who
are working in disaster response alright
thank you
[Applause]
all right so we're gonna do questions
but I have about ten seconds left for
that so if I don't wants to find me
afterwards I'm happy to speak directly
[Applause]